no don't wake up don't wake up exercise
schools we can go to sleep
I wasn't ready I need quiet so I can
talk first I don't know what that means
what is he doing right now what is he
doing
I don't like to put things over his head
I came here as a little bag right there
does he is dancing right now you have to
put him in the bag you just close it
okay hey this thing I can't even talk
because it won't shut its mouth shut
mouth I want to be a video with a Furby
because I usually can I let them leave
and try me
routine video you will shut your mouth
it's not funny hi guys were Christmas
actually I kind or if it's arrow
no what if you can't you know Malkina
yeah if you hold it back if you if you
poke him he gets ticklish wait I think
what is wrong with me seizing this thing
does not have a high have an off button
doesn't have an off button
yeah what do you think about it I don't
like it
you can make it evil you should have to
overfeed it the guy you meet it yeah
I'm gonna lose yeah well so I'm here
you're gonna have abs have you
uncomfortable yeah I don't really know I
just really don't worry good he's got
keep eating them if you feed him enough
he'll just hey what are you get it you
just burn no you Kristin I want him to
go away
no get away from me doesn't want to
anything it's just because amel canary
shut up okay wait here we go
just think so dumb
Pig say something no you'd let him on
fire I love this letter does it actually
really work when you catch a key
I couldn't she's sleeping oh he looks
nice now burp you got a mohawk
I didn't even it out a little just
forever just a tip just don't burn his
pink her kids don't try this at home
please because your parents will kill
you wait wait I'm gonna get this little
on right there that's good Oh No Oh
Faden in general I I've seen us let's
play a song for him what's all shut
everybody up
okay guys whatever you guys lose the
creepiest toy that you better save
because I this is definitely not the
fridge Minnesota's on fire what's
creepier tell your expert Teddy Ruxpin
is my dog he thinks this is music so
he's dancing now and he's not supposed
to be dancing oh but thanks Caleb oh
well done with him
now you just broke something
you found me Furby